delivery of the message is just as
important if not even more important
than the point you're trying to make you
may be right your delivery is so bad
that you push the person away from
whatever argument you're trying to make
to them there's a lot of people on
social media and I'll push back on your
uh what you just said a little bit on
one of the points it's easy for us to
just go hang out with each other where
we agree with each other it's very safe
to do been doing nothing special you're
not doing what these great leaders did
in the past just sitting there talking
to each other and we all agree hey let's
just go talk to people hey Pat why don't
you come on this platform everybody
agrees with you I don't want to go to a
platform where everybody agrees with I
want to go on a platform where people
don't agree with me I want people to
stop in the middle of the street and say
you know I don't agree with what you
said about this this I said tell me what
it was about that upset you let's
process it together I think we we have
to almost have some of those tough
conversations do something with it try
to figure out a way to persuade then if
we don't succeed then we got to take a
different route but I do think we have
to talk to the opposition side instead
of just people that agree with us